vous vous passez votre confinement
chaussettes blanches sans changer de
t-shirt et sans prendre de douche chaque
jour sans compter que vous avez pris une
dizaine de kilos en deux semaines à
force de piocher toutes les heures dans
votre frigo mayonnaise et pâte à
tartiner
vous n'êtes pas le seul mais cristiano
ronaldo lui a visiblement décidé de
prendre un autre chemin que celui de la
déchéance lui aussi en confinement au
portugal son pays d'origine le
footballeur de la juventus profite de
ces moments en famille pour s'occuper de
lui ne comptez pas sur ronaldo pour se
relâcher plus décidé que jamais à faire
gonfler ses pecs le champion passe ses
journées à faire du sport vous voulez
une preuve
en voilà une menace de son côté émilie
rattache cox qui en plein confinement
affolé ses fans avec une danse sexy
baylet a dit il quand elle s'est
totalement lâché sur tik tok et enfin
kylie jenner n'a pas hésité à dévoiler
un souvenir très chaud de ces vacances
bref il n'ya pas à dire à la sortie du
confinement tout le monde ne va pas
avoir le même succès sur les api de
rencontre mais franchement ça fait du
bien ça de voir ça non r des malouines
là et au run et ça fait du bien ça ouais
c'est rigolo un quelque peu mais lourd
n'a pas la même vie que ces gens là il y
voit et il s'amuse à leur manière à eux
ils sont dans notre monde mais je ne
connais pas tu pourrais faire la même
photo que cristiano ronaldo doit là j'ai
pas envie qu'il est heureusement alors
vous êtes-vous fait quitter cristiano
ronaldo sophie koch tout passer votre
style de mec
ouais il est pas mal oui pas mal bien
sûr bah oui les toits laurent et non pas
du tout non pas du tout s'est passé pas
votre cas pourquoi il est bien plastique
rose barbie elle dit
voilà voilà
oui on est lui prêt ses cuisses anneaux
ronaldo ne met que j'adore il est d'un
professionnalisme est ordinaire sans
arrêt une hygiène de vie comme ça et je
suis persuadé que c'est pas du de la
gauche fait c'est parce qu'il a c'est un
vrai sportif il arrive tout le temps
avant les entraînements et ça m'a appelé
il est uni
il s'occupait des orphelinats il y en a
quelques-uns au fait là ça m'étonne rixe
aurait offert jusqu'à que c'est un vrai
professionnel et il en tissant dodier
d'abord l'âge et qu'il a souffert ce qui
était encore à jouer c'est que c'est
vraiment un vrai pro et celle de
musculation et c'est un amour de la
cristiano ronaldo on lui fait un gros
bisou si si si son bill sus aux bisous
harry